[Music]
despite trying to avoid it as much as
possible the witcher is filled with cgi
from entire cities to prosthetics to the
magical elements we'll be taking a look
at it all check it out i believe there
are 133 shots in that sequence and 132
of them involve vfx number one you gotta
do what you gotta do
this is the moment before we meet our
friends the basilisks as they appear
through a portal while most of the scene
leading up to this shot isn't cgi it's
quite understandable why a green screen
may have come in handy
trying to be all stoic and serious and
then there's a guy in in green spandex
number two here come the terrifying lime
green lizard heads you've really got to
be willing to pretend as an actor
sometimes especially in the fantasy
genre you know it's going to look
awesome in the end but honestly
sometimes it's hard to take your job
seriously when you're trying to be all
stoic and serious and your acting
partner is supposed to be a scary
basilisk but instead it's just a bright
green head on a stick operated by a guy
in spandex
i sometimes would giggle but with
imagination on their side they manage i
love the illusion world i love to
visualize everything number three if we
turned people into trees we could solve
climate change think about it paul
bullion took on the role of aleshia in
season 2. the entirety of the leshi's
face is all prosthetics which is pretty
sweet we can't imagine how long that
took to apply every day all of the vines
growing off of his head though is where
the cgi magic comes in and who is geralt
attacking
that doesn't look like a leshi to us
nope just a guy flinging around a pool
noodle
okay it's probably not a pool noodle
before we started filming we had to do
quite a bit of training number four the
grass is always green screened somewhere
else we spotted some green screens in
the training scenes too trying to block
out their not so perfect location to
replace it with their mountaintop
destination later on
also is it just us or are the green
ropes new they must be way easier to
edit out in post than the black ones
and if you look closely freya allen
really isn't dodging a thing
i love all the stunt stuff it's so much
fun
number five beautifying the beast you
might be surprised to find out that the
creation of nivalin required little cgi
he was dressed in full costume the only
cgi was his face and i have like tons of
dots and and a camera all the time but
christopher hibiew absolutely loves that
his eyes are his own how they made the
eyes look like mine is just beautiful
work so why the cgi and not just
prosthetics have you said that a reason
is that often beasts don't display
complex emotion but he needed to
justified and it looked great
number six two halves is more effective
than one this scene from episode one of
the witcher is probably a personal fave
it isn't often an actor does all of his
own stunts and check out how he's only
got half a sword that's how he managed
to do some of these cool more dangerous
maneuvers in one shot it allows for a
lot more moves although the other actors
did find it a bit of a struggle because
they needed to match their weapons with
the invisible half of the sword
perfectly number seven if the sword
doesn't work try hitting him with a shoe
vladimir furtick who played the night
king in game of thrones choreographed
the fight between geralt and the
kikimora he acted out the scenes he was
choreographing by standing four people
on a table and giving them each a pair
of pipes to act as legs animating two
legs is hard enough let alone eight they
had to watch the footage at a quarter
speed to make sure it was moving
properly julian perry confessed it was
tricky to keep the creature balanced and
attacking at the same time and who could
forget all that splashing that's all cgi
too
number eight this next one's pretty hot
magic is definitely one of those
elements that is hard to create without
special effects and a lot of cgi tricks
went into shooting this scene the
working skin trick is done using a whole
bunch of different mask-like layers in
different stages of decay and just
blending them all together it makes
total sense but how come we never
thought of that before and check out all
of the work that goes into making the
fireballs
and how about how they're launching
people across the room
why does that look like so much fun
number nine the creature that feeds on
nightmares did the striga creep you out
as much as it did us while the entire
costume was prosthetics including the
dangly umbilical cord overall the
character required a blend of cgi too
they completely redesigned the character
out of special effects for some of the
more
inhuman stunts
we'd say it's impressive but we know
your trick cgi designers you have your
character hide in the darkness to make
it easier to blend the cgi with the real
effects
and the actors were having a blast
they had three artists playing the role
becky wright played the human form but
they had two other performers playing
the creature number 10 we actually
preferred the little guys with their
green suits showing to our surprise the
ghouls were not totally made of cgi the
proof is in the selfies wholesome
content alert oh how cute are these
boy does that suit look uncomfortable
though and eating looks like a major
struggle they were running out of time
to craft these scenes which is why they
landed on a halfway point between
prosthetics and special effects number
11. literal world building it's actually
amazing the kind of work that goes into
creating the buildings for fantasy
series remember how much time you would
spend building your dream house in the
sims or even a small community
this is like next level sims right here
number 12 ironically nothing about this
nature is real
layer after layer after layer added on
painstakingly to bring this forest to
life not even geralt and roach are real
here just leads you to wonder is
anything real just kidding and like
let's talk about posada that too was
entirely modeled from scratch vfx
supervisor julian perry said almost
every minute of this series is a visual
treat which means it required you
guessed it cgi
as finding that perfect location was a
struggle given they were filming in
budapest in the middle of winter
there's no cutting corners with crafting
these cgi bad boys
now these guys seem like they're a
little
lacking in the detail department but we
still like them well enough what they
lack in cgi they sure do make up in
storytelling layers it's all layers
bone structure muscle skin
they definitely weren't skipping steps
when they created him except for maybe
the scales and all these layers remind
us of a line from shrek onions have
layers ogres have layers well dragons
have layers too and lots of them
number fourteen we're gonna need some
cgi sleeves to go with these cgi armies
only about 30 or so people were real out
of this entire army do you think they
craft every tiny person by hand or do
you think they have a copy paste button
drawing a picture is hard enough let
alone layer after layer of designing
creatures and buildings we'll stick to
pencil crayons and stick figures thank
you very much what effect did you find
most interesting let us know in the
comments and thanks for watching